look at this I took 9 million steps
today okay so that's Sonic that one the
one that everyone has been dunking on
for the past three days is not the Sonic
we're getting on the big screen
this story is crazy the sonic trailer
dropped on Tuesday and people hated the
design of Sonic so much that they're
actually going to redesign the character
I know
director Jeff Fowler tweeted thank you
for the support and the criticism the
message is loud and clear you aren't
happy with the design and you want
changes it's going to happen
everyone at Paramount and Sega are fully
committed to making this character the
best he can be hashtag sonic movie
hashtag gotta fix fast yeah they do
let's see if they get rid of the human
teeth the movie doesn't come out until
November so I gotta be honest I had my
suspicions that maybe he wasn't fully
rendered or they were gonna tweak some
stuff but a full redesign with six
months to go I'm impressed and by the
way that tweet from the director is
full-on class gotta go fast
sonic not being stylized how risa seeing
him was about the only problem I had
with this trailer he's voiced by Ben
Schwartz Jim Carrey's there that was
never a big video game guy but now
obviously I'm gonna lie and say I am and
there's some great Easter eggs Laden
throughout this trailer the city or town
that they're in is called Green Hills
Green Hill Zone is in the game first
level the Paramount logo has the rings
he does a little power spin at one point
and the trailer says every hero has a
Genesis which is the most clever call
out to Sega Genesis Sonic's console his
home Ben Schwartz loves Sonic by the way
and gave us a little more insight to
some Easter eggs we're going to see tell
me about being a part of the movie were
you a gamer I was a gamer so I play the
voice of Sonic the Hedgehog which is as
someone who yes and the way that I see
him is like he's this childish like
excited kid he's funny his attitude if
in the video game I know these are nerdy
references but like he wagged his finger
he stomps if you take too long so I
tried to bring all that comedy aspect to
it and bring like the energy and
excitement to it and then you have Jim
Carrey yeah I'm gonna be right or die
for this movie especially after Jeff
fellers tweet I mean come on he's made
it clear he wants to make something for
the fans and that's great sonic the
hedgehog is out November 2019 and of
course I'll keep you updated on the
latest I'm ash Crossin see you next time
[Music]